my name is jessica Mackellar I am a CTO
I'm sorry I'm a found in the CTO of
pilot comm which is a bookkeeping firm
that is powered by software is my third
company so I should probably consider
myself an entrepreneur but that's not
actually how I think about myself I
think about myself as an activist who
happens to be one and my story tonight
is about how I came to think about
myself in that way so to do this I want
to introduce you to two people in my
life the first person I want to
introduce you to is Sam I've never met
Sam Sam is a person I know on the
internet and Sam emailed me one day
because he had questions about how to
think about how to learn to program and
he was emailing me because I've produced
a bunch of open-source intro to
programming material that lives online
and so he emailed me and he was asking
for some tips and tricks and I read his
email and I and I replied to those
questions but in reading his email it it
seemed to me like there might be a
question behind the questions that he
was asking and in my reply to Sam I
asked him why he wants to learn how to
program I'm gonna read you his response
because I get emails like this pretty
frequently and there they have a pretty
powerful impact on how I think about the
world
Sam says thanks for the response I'm
actually in Stephenville Texas I guess
not far from Austin but if you compare
the two it's a pretty big difference
it's a college town but if your first
vehicle isn't a tractor you don't really
fit in why do you ask
I've been learning to program but it
comes and goes it's a problem with
studying or procrastination but I've
been better lately I'm currently doing
phone tech support for a less than usual
rate per hour and they'll pile on tons
more things but the idea of the smallest
raise is a huge inconvenience to
them if raises occur it's only in dreams
and even then unlikely I get yelled at
all day
don't make enough it's the American
dream I think maybe you're starting to
see where I'm coming from
I'm just very unhappy with my current
life and job and it's stagnant and I
only make enough to still be behind I
can't learn or improve it's only the
exact same day in and day out I
want something where my skills are
actually appreciated
maybe compensated about the minimum for
once in my life I've been on the other
side of this fence for too long and I
just feel like giving up it's my second
email from Sam Sam we're just getting to
know each other it's gonna take a little
while to unpack this but Samuel I've
kept corresponding and and then helping
him think about some programming
projects and Sam has Sam has multiple
things going on in his life but at the
end of the day Sam is a guy from a small
town in Texas who just wants to live a
life that is meaningful and valued so
Sam is the first person I wanted to
introduce you to the second person's
name is sha and sha is a smart and
charismatic leader who cares deeply
about the idea of entrepreneurship he
sees that as a way to be creative and to
build things that can make people's
lives better he also sees it as a way to
redistribute wealth and he also sees it
as a way to create opportunities for
yourself if you're in an environment
where you might not have very many Shaw
is also currently incarcerated at San
Quentin State Prison he's serving a
seven he's been in for 17 years and he's
serving time for assault with a firearm
and he's got quite a ways to go Shaak
committed a serious crime and he's paid
dearly for it
but he's also transformed his life over
the past 17 years and has frankly
probably worked harder than I will ever
have to do on anything in my life to
demonstrate to society that he is worth
a second chance she was also a guy who
wants to be able to build something
meaningful and valued and so to explain
why I'm connected to
Sam and to Shaw I actually did take us
backwards in time a little bit I need to
take us back to when I lived in Boston
and I was bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
and fresh out of school and I was
working as a software engineer at a
company founded by some friends of mine
out of MIT so I had my work stuff doing
my thing and one day a friend of mine
named Ashish came up to me said hey
Jessica I have a project for us
okay she's what's up I've noticed that
there are no women in the Boston Python
user group and you know Python I know
Python what if we made it like a project
to get more women into this user group
because it's a really good group like
the people are good the content is good
why is it only dudes okay this sounds
like an interesting project yeah let's
do it
and we we brainstormed on on ways to
tackle this problem and we drew
inspiration from some outreach
initiatives that were happening out west
and we devised this intro to programming
in Python curriculum that we taught as a
series of weekend workshops and
initially were really bad at it because
we hadn't written like we hadn't taught
before we hadn't developed curricula
before but we learned a lot through each
iteration of this introductory workshop
and it started working we started
advertising these workshops and they
developed a reputation for being pretty
good and in particular for being a
really welcoming and accessible place
for new programmers and so these
workshops kept running and they started
filling up really quickly and actually
this had a transformative effect on the
user group the user group actually ended
up quadrupling in size to becoming the
largest Python user group in the world
in large part due to these outreach
efforts and the people directly impacted
by these efforts but also the signaling
that it provided more broadly in the
community but this was a place that
cared about diversity and inclusion and
was welcoming to people of diverse
backgrounds and so we were running his
workshops and we've been running with
him for about a year and then a really
important thing happened at a user group
event this woman named Reece a who had
gone through she actually gone through
the intro workshop twice
she came up to me and she wanted to tell
me something Risa had been out of the
workforce for a while she's been
focusing on raising her daughter and she
had decided that she wanted to get back
into things and in particular she wanted
to be a software engineer but she had no
prior programming experience and and so
she had gone to these intro workshops
and she had worked very hard in a very
focused way to prepare herself to apply
for software jobs and she came up to me
yet one of these user events to say that
she'd finally done it so six months
beforehand she had not known how to
program and she went through these intro
workshops and she wanted to tell me that
this was really the kick in the pants
that she needed to really focus on this
and she had worked very hard and she
landed a job as a software engineer and
she was starting in a couple of weeks
and that was really exciting to me
because that wasn't I hadn't intended to
build up a system that might potentially
change someone's life in quite that way
and the fact that it was having this
unintended consequence was really
powerful to me and I was thinking about
this in the car on the way home and I
was thinking it's cool we've run his
intro to programming workshops it's cool
that we say got a job wait what problem
are we solving again we aren't there any
women in this user group actually like
do I actually understand why that's
happening also actually why aren't there
any people of color in this user group
actually remind me again who has like
the opportunity to take programming
classes and actually who has access to a
computer at home so they might even be
able to experiment with this stuff oh
this isn't actually about Python
and and you start realizing that the
disparities that you see in like this
this tiny little this tiny little idea
like this idea of an open-source user
group the disparities that you see who
is there and who isn't are a reflection
of some very fundamental disparities in
society that we've collectively created
around education and access and
representation and stereotypes and this
point my 22 year old mine is like open
because when you start doing this root
cause analysis on why there are no women
in a programming user group you realize
that while you can implement the
tactical fix of running a programming
workshop if you want to actually solve
this problem you have to reach back to
these really fundamental societal
inequalities and address those at that
point congratulations you're an activist
and you can't really turn back so at
that point my commitment to this work
really grew I became a director for the
Python Software Foundation which is a
non-profit behind the language I
produced a bunch of material programming
material that I made freely available
online so people can learn from it I
joined the staff of PyCon which is a
large open-source conference to work on
inclusion and representation and
concurrent with that I had my work life
where I was busy building companies and
building teams and then I started paying
attention to these bigger picture issues
in a in a more intentional way I started
caring about voting riots I bought an
American flag cat suit and started
running polling stations during
elections I started paying attention to
criminal justice reform and in
particular investing money and time and
initiatives bringing the stories of
people who are incarcerated to the
public because I believe that empathy
around that will be a prerequisite to
reform and I'm definitely out of time
that's too bad and at some point in that
process I had the single most important
realization that I've had as an adult
human being which is that the work that
I do inside of work and the work that I
do outside of work are actually the same
thing and the work is always about
building a diverse and inclusive
community that is doing the right thing
and this realization is important this
realization is important because it
reframed how I think about what my job
is because my job today is only
peripherally to be the CTO of a tech
company this company is one of a
constellation of opportunities in my
life to connect people and do the hard
work of pushing the community design
into a more just place so this is why
half of the people that I work with in
my company are people that I met doing
open-source community building and why
my engineering team is 50% women that's
why the people from work are also the
people building job training programs
for incarcerated people with the
California Department of Corrections
that's how I ended up in a room with
Shaw and 15 other lifers at San Quentin
State Prison talking about technology in
the criminal justice system as part of a
journalism class at the institution
which is how I met Shaw that time
working this is a true story I'm working
with guys who graduated from that job
training program at San Quentin that was
built by my co-workers to submit talks
to PyCon which is this programming
conference that I've been running
diversity and inclusion initiatives for
the past five years when I say it's all
connected it's really all connected and
this is why I always answer emails from
people like Sam who's just a guy from a
small town in Texas who wants to have a
chance to live a life that's meaningful
and that's why shot knows that if he
ever gets out he always has a job with
me
so this stuff is all connected and I am
so grateful to have had the opportunity
to experience these open-source things
early and and realize this orientation
for my life because it's had a profound
impact on Who I am as a person as well
as as a manager and as a leader and
that's how I became an activist who
happens to be an entrepreneur
[Applause]